let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people people is not
Liberty you [__] eating [__] ah the
smell of freedom of speech this is the
Tony Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
them well happy happy happy hump
day today is
Wednesday 4:00 Eastern 3:00 Central you
know what that means it is time for
let's talk the Tony Michaels podcast I
am the Tony Michaels and boy do we have
a show for you today a lot of big news
in the Tony Michaels podcast world today
number one we have some great special
guests here on the podcast today we have
Brett and Jordy melis of the minest
touch podcast and midest touch uh we're
going to play a little trivia game it's
uh brother love sportsball as we like to
call it here on the podcast so we will
we will show you that interview today um
they also uh mention a lot about the
midest mighty we asked him about the
mest mighty I was very curious about the
midest mighty and how that pertains to
mest touch and where that came from and
uh I was very curious about how that
mest Mighty Coalition came about so they
talk a lot about the midest mighty today
also I want to announce and introduce
today we'll we'll we'll bring him in
here in a little bit after the [__] list
uh Gabe Sanchez is our new executive
producer here at the show yay if we had
s effects we we'd give Applause or
something so we're very excited to have
Gabe not only are we excited to have
gab's uh detail to content we're in his
script writing his his background art
but also all the wigs he brings with it
we really are excited about all the wig
wearing that we will possibly have on
the show here so that's all very very
very exciting stuff that is new to the
podcast but also we have a 2hour format
I don't know if you heard but we are
going from a one-h hour format to a
2hour format here at the Tony Michaels
podcast uh the format is going to be the
[__] list where we're going to rant and
Rave and give them the [__] them style
the [__] them attitude [__] them every
week on the very first part of the
podcast we'll do the [__] list as you
know we do the [__] list Roundup every
day every weekday on Twitter and twitch
where we go surf the trendy Trends and
the Tweety tweets to round up all the
[__] on the Twitter list and we call it
the [__] list Roundup and because we
round up all those topics we pick the
best ones out of the Roundup and put
them right here on N Tony Michaels
podcast in in the section the segment
that we call the [__] list so we'll be
getting to that soon we we're also going
to have more creative segments on the
podcast where we create different types
of content we're going to try to make
you laugh we're really focusing on this
mess messaging thing and really trying
to get the Democrats to have better
messaging they [__] suck at messaging
and we need to get them better we need
to push them towards that direction even
if we got to do a little laughs and
comedy to do that and that's very very
very important and and in the interview
we actually uh talk about with Brett and
Jordy from myou we actually talk a
little bit about messaging um um in that
interview so stay with us because that
is going to be the last part of the
podcast today is the interview with
Brett and Jordy from the mightest touch
so stay tuned for the whole two hours
today here on YouTube Twitter twitch
again we're live on YouTube Twitter
twitch uh you'll be able to download the
podcast in its two hour format after
we're done recording we'll post it up
just like we always have done it'll just
be 2 hours instead of an hour and you'll
be able to go download it on Apple
Spotify and all those great places and
be sure be sure to uh follow uh us on
Twitch Go download the Twitch app
to keep track of that [__] list Round Up
everyone's liking that [__] list Roundup
where we where we round up all the
Tweety tweets and the trendy trends
Friends of the day so go download the
Twitch app it's very important that the
Twitch app I'm I don't get paid by
twitch I'm just saying download a Twitch
app it's easy to watch the twitch the
Twitchy twitch there and you can go
explore twitch which I don't know if you
want to that's like a that's a crazy ass
rabbit hole it's kind of like these q
and hors down here at
Dallas uh waiting on JFK Jr twitch is
kind of like that kind of like kind of
like that there's some crazies on there
there's some crazies on there I'm just
warning you about that Twitch app we're
also on our new format are gonna have
commercial breaks and we want to make
you laugh during the commercial breaks
so
you'll you will see and a lot of this a
lot of this great content comes from
Gabe Sanchez himself especially today so
uh I hope you enjoy this and join us
here every Wednesday 3 o'cl central four
4 o'clock Eastern but right now let's
let's we're going to go to the [__] list
but the first thing I want to do is I
want to take a quick break right after
this we will be back with the [__]
list we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast trying to remember all the
things you boycotted can really get you
stressed because there's no good way to
keep them from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just
$29.99 plus you'll also receive our next
stap as a bonus just Loop it around your
neck to travel with ease but call right
now and we'll double the offer that's
two boycott binders and two neck straps
for just
$29.99 boycott binders brought to you by
the same makers of binders full of women
catch Tony's twitch stream the [__] list
Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thony Michaels we're back to
the king of Brilliance this is the Tony
Michaels
podcast
welcome back to the show thank you for
hanging in on the break there with
us now we get to the real
meat of the [__] a attitude here on the
Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast we are going to bring in the
[__] list you guys know we do the [__]
list round up every week and I want to
explain this real quick so we we go on
Twitter and twitch every day weekdays
noon Eastern 11 Central and we we surf
Twitter we surf the Tweety tweets and
the trendy Trends on the [__] list round
lip and what we do is find the shittiest
topics out there in our democracy that
are challenging our democracy the most
and I tend to do what I tend to do which
is rant and rave on the [__] list
Roundup but then I take those topics the
most important ones are the most talked
about ones are the most trendy of the
trendy of the
trendiest and bring them here on the
Tony Michaels podcast in a segment we
like to call the [__] list the [__]
list so let's get into the [__] list
here we are with the [__] list first up
on the [__] list is infrastructure now
as you know as you know the Democrats
delivered a physical infrastructure
package to the American people Joe Biden
gets a win Republic
could have had a win but they they think
that a win for Joe Biden is radical
socialism and there's no way that
they're going to tolerate any kind of
win even if it's even if it's like you
know physical infrastructure highways
roads Bridges you know stuff so you
don't have [__] potholes so your
Bridges aren't falling into the water
you know [__] like that you know a
highspeed internet who wants that kind
of socialism this is all [__]
nonsense this ridiculous ass thing where
these Republicans
are trying to spew this garbage about
how infrastructure is radical socialism
and going to destroy our democracy there
is nothing more pro-democracy than
people coming together in the form of
government we the people to create
infrastructure that not only makes our
way of life and our better but also to
better our economy make sure our economy
stays on track Jesus Christ you turn on
Fox News Newsmax oan right-wing talk
radio and the only [__] two things
they can talk about is the containers
offshore oh Joe Biden empty shells Biden
all this [__] and and the crisis at
the
border which two things those two things
are no more infrastructure than anything
else in this country those are
infrastructure problems you would say
and I actually believe that there's
probably not enough infrastructure in
the 1.2 physical infrastructure in the
1.2 trillion dollar bill that Democrats
and Joe Biden no Republicans by the way
hardly no Republicans we'll talk about
that here in a
second actually got passed and got for
the American people you had Chuck Todd
at
[__] Joe Biden signing the bill he's
saying oh look this is a defeat for
Democrats defeat defeat for Democrats
how is this a defeat for
Democrats it's somehow somehow we're a
year away from election and because
they're signing a bill that delivers
$1.2 trillion of infrastructure money
into the American people's pockets into
their communities for jobs roads Bridges
high-speed internet somehow that's a
loss Chuck Todd you [__] this is this
is the problem with messaging this is
the [__] problem Republicans have
always painted the lam stream media
MSNBC CNN ABC CBS NBC always have
painted them as the liberal media the
liberal media and because people like
Chuck Todd hate the hate the [__]
words liberal media want to want to try
to seem oh well we're not liberal so
they try to do this thing where they
intentionally find problems with the
Democratic party with the Democratic
president the Democratic Congress
intentionally as matter of fact
manufacture [__] just like tou CH Chuck
Todd was doing on TV the other day while
Joe Biden was was signing the
infrastructure bill that's going to
deliver $1.2 trillion to the American
people in the form of infrastructure in
their communities this isn't like some
kind of [__] Pie in the Sky type
thing this is real [__] that they're
going to see and feel Bridges roads
high-speed internet tangible real [__]
that the American people are going to
feel and I tell you what's going to
happen here if Democrats do not get
their messaging straight and do not
because here's what Democrats do oh we
won we won now let's move on to the next
thing let's move on to the next fight
inside of our party right that's what
happens let's move on to the next fight
inside of our
party well Democrats you need to not
worry about the next fight inside the
party you need to sell this
infrastructure bill because we're also
going to get the big bird bill I call it
the Big Bird bill cuz build back better
here's another [__] problem with
Democratic messag you can't even hardly
[__] say the bill bill back Bild the
bill back the bill back the better Bill
back the better you better build you
better I I better build shut the [__] up
the Big Bird Bill we'll call it that
because they got the BBB thing going
already but we need to get future
messaging a lot easier for people to
understand what the hell does that mean
Bill back better it's human
infrastructure Universal prek it gives
family leave it gives education past
high school for a two years associates
degree or trade school like it's real
[__] you could almost call it you could
almost call it the freedom in parents
education
act yeah there you go
education cuz it's human infrastructure
it's real human infrastructure that the
American people not only want but
they've needed for years and I tell you
what's going to happen with not only
this human infrastructure bill but it's
also going to happen with the physical
infrastructure Bill Republicans are
going to be out there and they're going
to be selling the hell out of this oh
look what the well look what we did for
you they're going to be in their
districts believe you me next year in
these midterms they're going to be
running saying oh look look what we did
for you look we deliver for you American
people we deliver high-speed internet we
deliver good roads good Bridges we did
all this for you and they [__] voted
against it and Democrats need to be on
this we need to not we need to not sit
back and let them we need to punch we
need to punch and punch and punch and
punch this is a big political fight that
we are going to have to have and we are
going to have to win this political
fight cuz let me tell you something if
they're messaging wins here this qanon
CRT JFK Jr two and on cult Voodoo if
this messaging wins if this messaging
wins and I'm going to talk about this
here in a second with Steve Bandon and
Kyle ritten house because that's all
part of this culture War message that's
why they hold Steve Bandon up that's why
they hold writtenhouse
up and this Written House trial this is
why they want this culture War they want
it because if they win they'll win the
house in 2022 and here's their plan
here's their qanon cult Voodoo plan is
to put Donald Trump a speaker of the
house are you listening ing out there
people who vote do you want Donald Trump
to be the speaker of the house because
that is their plan with this messaging
they are going to go out there and they
going to sell in their districts they
are going to sell they are going to
sell that infrastructure bill that they
did it and they're going to sell Steve
Bannon and Kyle Rittenhouse domestic
terrorism so let's move on to Steve
Bannon as you know Steve Bannon was not
just held in criminal content of
Congress he was also charged by the doj
and he was arraigned on Monday
now he was very excited about this he
was very excited because this gets his
base all riled up The Written House type
that's that's the that's what they're
trying to do that's what they're trying
to stoke they're trying to stoke
political violence they're trying to
stoke division inside of our
politics and how they are going to do it
how they are going to do it is they are
going to use these cultural issues like
the Kyle Written House trial like Steve
Banning being a political prisoner like
today the qanon shaman being being
sentenced to 41 months in prison because
they're political prisoners you know
Marjorie Taylor green hoofoot goes on
Steve bannon's War Room goes on social
media and perpetuates this stuff we had
we we have Paul gozar we have Mo Brooks
perpetuating this garbage as political
PR Jesus Christ even the Big Bird stuff
from Ted Cruz saying that that that big
bird is government
propaganda that's part of this Written
House Steve Bannon culture war and we
cannot let them take this messaging away
and the thing that we have to focus on
is to let these systems work but also to
send the message out there and the
message has to be that we have to be Pro
democracy cuz Steve Bannon and the gqp
and the cult q and non Voodoo is not
pro- democracy it's not Steve Bannon
trying to commit a Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup in an attempt to plan the Cheeto
dust kangaroo coup I mean Jesus during
his arraignment when he was walking in
the courthouse someone was holding a
[__] sign that says coup
plotter like in the background behind
him it says cou plotter and he had a big
smile on his face he's like you goddamn
right you're godamn right we want a
coup this is what their followers want
we act like we act we we're acting like
Steve banon being arraigned on federal
charges whether they're misdemeanor or
not being arraigned on federal charges
is a win is a win for the
country they see him as a
martyr that's what they see him as and
we have to act as such we have to act as
such so we have to be Pro democracy here
we cannot let down our guard this is
very important their plan is to commit
another coup they are in the process of
committing another coup Jesus he stood
outside the the courthouse after the
judge released him of his own
recognizance w- which is only the
assumption that he turned over his
passport and a few other conditions that
the federal judge the federal magistrate
would put on him he stood there he
pointed at the camera and said you
messed with the wrong guy Joe Biden
Nancy Pelosi and the woke mob and you
know Big Bird and whoever else their
[__] cultural enemy is
here we can't just sell infrastructure
we can't just get $1.2 trillion in money
we can't just make sure that the
American people don't have to deal with
inflation Democrats can deal with these
issues
they can deal with them in Congress they
can deal with them in DC but
infrastructure dealing with inflation
dealing with the the supply chain crisis
and all these things are not a culture
War they are fighting the battle for
culture war on these issues they are
calling roads highways Bridges and
high-speed internet radical socialism
that is going to destroy our country
that's what they're saying that's what
they're saying they know infrastruct
that they know that's not what it is
they don't give a [__] and the reason
why they don't give a [__] it's because
they don't want democracy they don't
want it it's a cult it's a [__]
cult and we see it no more clearly than
in some of these trials going on around
the country not just with not just with
the select committee and the subpoenas
and them defying subpoenas is and saying
crazy ass [__] on crazy ass shows stuff
that we've never seen Americans say in
modern history about our government
about our our about our
democracy about political Norms about
culture wars in this country we've never
seen these people say these there are
people there are people still down in
Dallas they are waiting for JFK Jr to
show up so he can run with Donald Trump
in
2024 hundreds of them hundreds of cult
members of this CRT
JFK Q andon cult Voodoo they're there
waiting for him to show up on an alien
ship or I don't know out of a cardboard
box or to be awakened from the dead I'm
not really sure exactly what the plan is
with JFK Jr but these people are there
waiting their [__] waiting on him to
show up to run with Donald Trump that's
how delusional this stuff is but they
know one thing they know one thing about
this that this cultural War message
these these wedge issues that they drive
between us and they drive the messaging
they drive the messaging with it and by
driving I mean their base because we are
a big tent part party we're a big tent
party there's all kinds of us there's
there's the Bernie supporters there's
the moderates there's the Republicans
who are anti-trumpers in our party now
they're there they they're abandoned by
their the actual old the guard the go
now it's the
gqp they're here in our party and we're
not going to get along we're not going
to we're not going to be eye eye on
issues especially the details of issues
but there's one thing we all have in
common and that is pro democracy and we
cannot we cannot let them steal the the
message of anti anti democracy and
perpetuate the message of anti-democracy
in this country without having them pay
politically and speaking about spreading
an anti-democracy
message in this country there's
no it sickens me of this writtenhouse
trial and the judge so let's go to a
quick break and when I get back we're
going to talk about the writtenhouse
trial you sit your ass down sit the flip
down we're not finished the Tony
Michaels podcast we'll be right
[Music]
back
headline under President Joe Biden the
American economy gain steam by adding 5
131,000 jobs for the month of October
[__] a thanks Brandon
[Music]
the Tony Michaels podcast Wednesdays at
400 p.m. Eastern 300 p.m. central watch
live on YouTube on Twitter and twitch
download on Apple and Spotify now here's
[Music]
Tony welcome welcome welcome back
wellcome back to the [__]
list thanks for hanging with us in on
those
breaks so I told you that we were going
to get to this written house stal and
I've saved this for last because um I
I'm not sure we we could be getting
verdicts as I'm on air I I'm not really
sure where they are in the verdict but
there was there was a lot of right-wing
conspiracy last night on the Twitter and
on the internet um it's all a bunch of
horeshit they were talking about US
Marshals just this Jack piac or [__]
[__] Packa I don't know what the [__]
his name is the pizzagate guy Jack
pizzagate you know who I'm talking about
this [__] conspiracy theorist who
spreads lies on the internet on Twitter
why the [__] Twitter has him still with
a blue check mark I have no idea how in
the [__] is a person who spreads
conspiracy theories like pizzagate have
a verified account how the [__] is that
even possible I don't even I mean I
don't even know it's absolutely [__]
ridiculous that Twitter lets this person
pretend to be some any of them really
Candace Owens or any of
them but I'll digress from that issue
back to the writtenhouse trial he was
spreading last night this rumor about
how the US Marshals had showed up and
somehow they I don't know I don't know
what the [__] they were talking about
two jury were hold outs and and they
were scared of RI number one one US
Marshal this has nothing to do with the
federal government this is not a federal
trial it's not a federal trial it's not
an a federal court it's in a [__]
State Court that's one of the problems
that it has is in the state court this
[__] judge Schroeder or whatever the
[__] this guy's name is holy [__] this
guy has lost his goddamn mind all the
way from Christmas cookies to not being
able to understand what Zoom how Zoom
works on your [__]
iPhone to to to uh playing footsie with
Kyle writtenhouse in in the open
courtroom and then today he's yammering
on and on and on about the media he he
loves this attention this judge he
thinks he's some kind of celebrity and
he also it feels like he's Kyle
rittenhouse's Granddad his grandfather
I'm not really
sure but this Kyle Rittenhouse trial I
think the importance of it is no matter
what what the verdict no matter what the
verdict the right-wing's message is
going to be
violence it's going to be hard violence
they don't care if he's found guilty if
he's found innocent they don't care they
don't care what the outcome is is of
this trial they only
care about what violence they can Stoke
because that's the whole
purpose of the Kyle Written House trial
and holding him up as a [__] hero in
the first
place the gqp wants this brand of
Timothy MC Trump humping domestic
terrorism they want to breed they want
to breed more Kyle written houses
throughout the entire country what do
you think January 6th
was January 6th was the same stoking of
violence and fear that led Kyle
Rittenhouse to believe that there was a
a black lives matter protest and he
better go shoot some black lives matter
protesters cuz that's what happened
that's what happened the evidence in the
case if you've been paying attention
that's why he went he didn't go to
render Aid he's not a medic you don't
give you don't render [__] Medical
Aid with a goddamn AR15 that's all
[__] and he shot first and then when
they tried to to to portray this
self-defense this self-defense
[__] the video shows that he was
pointing his [__] rifle at people and
it caused other people who had the legal
ability to conceal Carrie to get their
weapons
out and again we could go into the whole
good guy bad guy argument but we'll
leave that for another [__]
day because the fact of the matter is is
that Kyle Rittenhouse went there to a
black lives Manor protest where they
were protesting the killing or the the
attempted killing of a white cop of a
black
man they were protesting and he heard in
his little white ears that it was a
black lives matter
protest and I wonder I wonder what Kyle
Rittenhouse could have thought I wonder
what he could have thought so much so
that he would take an illegal rifle that
was done on a straw purchase which the P
the straw purchaser is going to stand
trial and
probably uh be prosecuted and
incarcerated for that
crime for an illegal straw purchase to
give the gun to Kyle Rittenhouse so Kyle
Rittenhouse could go shoot black people
that's what he
thought and that is what the go the gqp
wants you to that's what they want their
supporters to think Kyle ritten house
thought Jesus Christ we had Mo Brook
talking about tying this all in with
this race Suburban oh they're going to
come and get you and come mess up your
yards where he's talking about
infrastructure and he's talking about
how black people are going to move into
white neighborhoods that's not what he
said but that's the [__] code
word that is the war they want to stoke
that is the message that they are
sending that's the culture war that they
want to have
that's it it's what it is it ain't got
nothing to do with $1.2 trillion doll or
or how many trillions of dollars on
human infrastructure or what kind of or
prek or or COL two years of college or
it ain't got nothing to do with a law
theory that's taught in law schools that
teaches the systematic racism of
government and legal systems that's not
what they're talking about that's not
what they give a [__] about
that's not what they're
saying what they're telling their
voters is you're losing your white
privilege you're losing it and if you
keep letting these Democrats in you're
going to lose more of it which is a
bface [__] lie all of it all of its
propaganda all of its lies but what do
we do about it what do we do about it if
we want to keep our democracy because
the goal of this
propaganda of of this this narrative
that writtenhouse is some kind of
[__] right-wing
superhero and and this messaging that
we're Bound for violence no matter
what I
mean Jack is Jack
posto is perpetuating on Twitter that no
matter what the outcome that there's
going to be violence they're trying to
stoke black lives matter left-wing
activists Progressive activist into
violence if it goes wrong which we
should not do that is one thing we
should not do is we as as Democrats as
the big tent when I I mean I mean
lowercase D that's one thing we need to
do is lowercase D Democrats what I mean
by that is people who are pro
democracy they're Pro
democracy democra or I don't know we
come up with a name for
it they're trying to provoke those
people who believe in democracy who
believe that the fabric of our country
is still
strong into violence because they want
violence folks just like they did on
January 6 that was the whole
point that was the whole point drive
drive people to go be violent in the
name of trump because if you can go
name of
trump and then Trump doesn't have to do
anything he can sit and watch it on a TV
screen how do you think these fascist
rulers get into power they don't
actually go they don't actually go swing
the flags and hit the cops they don't go
and kill the cops and stop on the cops
they don't go actually Bears spray the
cops they stand back and provoke others
to go do that their sheep their herd
their cult to go do that for them
that's what they're doing with this
Written House thing this Written House
thing is way way way bigger in this
country than just Kyle writtenhouse
being a
murderer way bigger and the reason why
it's way bigger is because the
right-wing the
gqp the qanon cult
voodooist want more written houses and
you're going to hear this I I almost am
betting that you're going to hear these
words The Written House rule or some
[__] [__] like
that it's going to be a code word just
like this let's go Brandon for [__] Joe
Biden they can't say we want you white
people to go murder black people they
can't say that we want you white people
to take your guns and go kill people in
political violence they can't say that
they have to say things like mole Brooks
is saying like oh the the the low income
housing where those those people live
you know what kind of people wink I'm
talking about are going to mess up your
white neighbor oh or your your suburban
neighborhoods I mean Trump tried this
[__] during the 2020 election when he
talked about Suburban moms you're going
to lose your your Suburbia and all this
[__] he did the same thing it's the same
it's the southern strategy but they're
doing it all over the country they're
trying to figure out where their white
privilege support their white supremacy
support their cult support is and they
want these people to be violent for them
they want it that's what they want and
we have to stop this messaging because
we have to come up with messaging of our
own and it it's not just it's not just
the politicians it's not just the
commentators it is Everyday People you
have to get out there and you have to
message to your neighbors your friends
your colleagues your family and have to
make them understand that all this stuff
is anti-democracy it's anti-democracy
we want pro-democracy if we want the
United States of America and we want the
Constitution and we want to live with
Liberty with rights and freedom to
deliver us that
Liberty that we must we must be Pro
democracy and we cannot we cannot
sacrifice our values for that so thanks
for joining me on the [__] list the [__]
list we're going to be right back after
these messages right back after these
messages
you sit your ass down sit the flip down
we're not finished the Tony Michaels
podcast will be right
[Music]
back
headline under President Joe Biden the
American economy gain steam by adding
53100 th jobs for the month of October
[__] a thanks
[Music]
Brandon the Tony Michaels podcast
Wednesdays at 400 p.m. Eastern 300 p.m.
central watch live on YouTube on Twitter
and twitch download on Apple and Spotify
now here's
Tony
welcome back to the
show I'm going to have to get better at
this commercial break
thing I apologize for playing two of the
same commercial breaks there but you
know it happens it happens when it's
your first try at a 2hour episode I mean
we've got a lot of stuff that we uh we
just got underneath the radar here cuz
I've got I've got my executive producer
in the wing here waiting to introduce
him because we're going to now now we
come to the part in the show of the new
format where uh we we do a we do a
little talkie talk we just kind of talk
and
uh we have we have um we have we have a
little fun where we we talk about
certain subjects maybe stuff that's
going on maybe stuff that's in the [__]
list but today we have a special topic
for you today that me and Gabe want to
talk about but but let me introduce you
to G Gabe Sanchez is an actor and
comedian he's actually been a guest on
the show and that's kind of how we got
connected here we got to talking about
content um and we really we really have
the same kind of idea that you know
content can move the needle content can
move messaging and you know we're going
to talk a lot about this messaging thing
so let's let's bring Gabe in uh to the
stream here hey Gabe how's it going hey
what's going on so Gabe is our new
executive producer thanks for joining us
today Gabe and thanks for uh being our
new executive producer everyone go
follow Gabe on all the the social tell
them where you're at Gabe on the socials
uh yeah you can find me uh am Gabe
Sanchez across everything the board he's
branded baby he's branded he's branded
so yeah you were guest on the on the on
the uh a podcast several weeks ago and
we got to talking about content and how
we could contribute and I had this idea
of doing more with the show and that's
kind of how we got connected right I
mean yeah cuz cuz we're trying to fight
this message uh like
um against some of these Bone Heads like
I think that the yeah Joe Rogan and and
a ton of other I mean like the you know
crazy people who are uh you know we'll
say unqualified to say stuff or to say
stuff uh just that is bad [__] crazy but
on the right especially it's just like
one after another after another after
another they're just nonstop with uh
with just racist uh homophobic uh uh or
conspiracy theories like there's no
there is no like filter for them and it
is run a muck right well I mean I mean
they they it's it's a prime example in
Joe Rogan's case because Joe Rogan
wasn't like always this like right-wing
crazy net job right no I mean like you
know he I think everyone remembers him
from The Fear Factor days and then he
you know jumped over his standup
comedian started doing you know his
podcast and then you know in the last
few years uh he's
definitely uh within marketing himself
to the MMA crowd political crowd what
have you like there is some crossover of
some weird people that should not be
given the the spotlight in a good way
did you ever W I mean did you listen to
his podcast or watch it on YouTube I've
seen some like uh I've seen some in the
past with other comedians or other
guests like that but that's what I
mainly watch like when I would watch it
was like when he had a comedian on or
something I never I never really I'm not
like an MMA fan so I never watched like
the MMA shows because that always seemed
to be his content was he had comedians
on or like someone who was newsworthy
right and then the MMA stuff because he
is he because uh and and again this is
just my assumption of what I know about
Joe Rogan is that he's kind of a host or
something of USC right I mean yeah he he
does a he does a a ringside comment
right right so so I mean it this this
whole this whole thing like I how do you
think he ended up with a right-wing
audience cuz I have my theory but I want
to hear yours and it's not really right
rightwing it's more like fragile fragile
it's this this toxic masculinity I think
I think for the very same reason like he
is uh you know he's not the mainstream
you know he's a he's a a a different
breed you know as people might say and I
think with that one he has an appeal to
a demographic that wouldn't say I'm
going to listen to read or watch the
news right he's got another group that
is average Joe wrestling MMA whatever
comedians like just normal like folks
right wouldn't be anyone who would be
like I'm an elitist you know um and I
think he has brought on guests that have
organically uh or unintentionally
brought up topics
and it's like a free form podcast where
they'll like ad hoc jump over to
something that was mentioned look it up
and either give validation to something
that isn't legitimate uh or or give
validation to someone who isn't
legitimate by bringing them on as a
guest and I think from there you know
realizing whether he sees a business
opportunity or what in terms of driving
the numbers but I think obviously
bringing on relatively controversial
people on other side specifically on
like like Alex Jones right exactly I I
mean like I just saw a photo today where
he was hanging out with Alex Jones well
yeah he was on Tim P's podcast with Alex
Jones him I I mean just the [__]
crazies of the crazies of the crazies
here he is right in the middle of it and
you know what you know what really gets
me about uh Joe Rogan is that um this he
complains you know because again I used
to listen to Joe Rogan show when there
was comedians especially if it was a
comedian that that I thought was funny
and I thought it would be a good
conversation cuz some of those
conversations were funny they were
entertaining
but I believe that he he's built this
audience with the message that you're
talking about where he gets to just play
a clip and it's real right there live on
the show and they get to believe that
it's real and then he gives them his tox
toxic masculinity Macho machismo take on
it right and then he might have Alex
Jones or some other Macho machismo toxic
mail on and and and he he just built
this audience with that with that
content and now he he's got the Spotify
he just got to talk to that audience
right just got talk to him and talk to
him and that's why he's hanging out with
Alex Jones and Tim P because there you
know if you do a VIN diagram I wonder
like how the audiences would uh overlap
what do you think oh yeah I I'm sure I'm
sure at some points you'd have a
complete circle uh but yeah I think that
there's you know the you know by him
going on the
podcast uh for Tim Po you know and
talking with Alex Jones and whoever else
like again he's
only further validating their talking
points right to say like these are
legitimate figureheads that can talk on
this subject as opposed to these are
people who are just giving their opinion
without facts you know um and I I think
it's it's a slippery slope and and I
don't you know we'll see what happens
with Spotify obviously it's a very
expensive deal and he's fine I think
he's I don't I don't think spotify's
walking away from that money no not at
all I mean he definitely has had to make
a couple statements you know uh regards
to a couple well right I mean but but
that's all that the this Alex Jones
slippery slope where Alex Jones is being
sued by Sandy Hook because he's saying
things that AR not only just
demonstrably false and not only defaming
but he's like it's intention is to sick
his supporters on these people to harass
them which um but then also at the same
time is uh be aggressive towards anyone
come at you and then also play victim
that no no no no no it's I they started
it uh I'm the victim here uh you know
and it's the same thing that that he did
with uh with the Judgment that happened
for the case and he's like I gave I gave
all the things and they said it was
doctored they're always victims
always just continue to be victims I
mean it's it's a thing that's going to
continue with these people
I mean that's that's the whole Joe Rogan
oh boohoo don't silence the white guy
white guy who has the biggest podcast
audience in the entire nation what are
you talking about silencing yeah you
have a Spotify deal and you have
millions of people who listen to your
spy YouTube Twitter like all over the
place God get the [__] out of here with
this being silenc crap so actually um I
don't know if you noticed but there's
this new uh News Network out have you
heard of this it's really news now have
you heard of this this uh yeah think I
saw maybe something I don't know maybe
maybe I if our audience hasn't uh seen
this yet I've got a clip I actually I
actually was on the real news now I was
a guest on a show it's called Uh I
believe it's called Zero Hour with Bill
with Bill Bryan's on
RNN yeah and I I was a guest and so was
Joe Rogan we were competing guest and
you remember you remember this ior
mechon um Aaron Rogers and then Joe
Rogan
treated yeah yeah yeah yeah so so
actually I think I think maybe if
there's not technical difficulties
here because there may have been some
technical difficulties right Gabe um if
there's not te technical difficulties
here I think we have a clip of that let
me see if I can play that
here welcome back to zero hour I'm Bill
Bryan with many professionals leaving
the medical field Americans are looking
for a new type of treatment from NFL
quarterbacks to nut job influencers this
turn against sound advice from your
doctor is beginning to carry the stench
of
horch podcasters are now the world's
leading experts in Therapeutics tonics
Elixir serums snake oils parasiticides
and yes even vac sces our country is now
in a different type of Remedy timeline
and tonight I'm joined by two podcasters
to discuss this berserk blueprint Joe
Rogan and Tony Michaels thank you both
for joining me Joe what gives you the
confidence to give anyone medical advice
related to the Corona virus well it's
not rocket surgery I threw the kitchen
sink at it and now I'm cured cured says
the guy took fuing horse D warmer Jesus
Christ it wasn't horse paste it was
prescribed by a doctor prescribed by a
doctor not iveron is a dewormer youing
bonehead you sound just like the woke
mob at CNN enough Gentlemen let's try to
rain it in Joe how do you go about
getting prescribed icon well a doctor of
course and let me be clear before I get
cancelled it was an online doctor where
does this doctor work the Florida Ivor
mechon Institute of qanon Technology
what are the batshit crazy stuff that
this doctor inject you with monoc clal
antibodies zpac antibiotics a vitamin
drip must be nice to have the hate ofing
afford that kind of [__] you anding
Karen Rogers both so Joe did Aaron
Rogers of the Green Bay Packers just
call you up for a prescription of ior
mechon yeah he consulted me about my
protocol and a Facebook DM protocol
Jesus [__] Christ Dr dunan Krueger
here thinks he's some kind of Co expert
what next you going to take a bath in
borax oh get off your fing high horse I
don't believe everything on the internet
you and the horse you rode in on oh this
horse gladly uh all right well thank you
both for joining me this evening wow not
sure if Joe was going for Dr Jackal or
Mr jackass but I'm Bill Bryan's and this
is the news you already
knew
so so uh uh aside of the uh the little
uh maybe technical difficulties there
that clip that clip seems completely
legitimate and completely real right he
I mean RNN sounds like a a real real
News Network really news now
like so so I hope I hope the audience
out there understands that that is not
real it is a it is a it is a network
that we have made up here on the show
and I hope I hope to
actually I hope to actually provide more
content uh through RNN and some of these
Outlets to uh uh to give cuz we' seen NL
I want to talk about this because uh
actually I think I think you had sent it
to me the clip of SNL's little thing on
the Ivor mechon and big bird um you
review tell me how you think SNL did
with that little so I I think yeah so I
think the sketch is a whole right it was
like Ted crw Street it was making fun of
Sesame Street and it had like the the
generic uh uh you know wishlist versions
of characters and I think overall the
joke like the whole sketch played well
different characters margar Taylor green
K Dracula or the the the uh not C Trula
um the the count and
um but with the Joe Rogan one it was
something so we had you know we had just
read about it so we did this little
thing and that night they made a
reference to Joe Rogan you know taking
evermon giving it to Big Bird but
however the overall reference of him
performing Flo on himself right so so
let's let's let's back up let's rewind
for a second because so um just so our
audience knows we wrote the sketch that
we wrote that you just seen we wrote it
before The Joe Rogan giving himself a
[__] story right because where did
that that where did that drop where like
what it was like uh it was on Newsweek
and it was on uh The Daily Dot it was
because he said it on his own he said it
on a podcast right but it was like in
this one moment where like yeah yeah
right off hand was like yeah you know I
I know I can suck my own dick right
right what it they're like how do you
know you can suck your own dick and he's
like I put my fa I'm like come on man I
put my I think the quote is I put my
face around it around just so I could
see what defin can we google the word
around
it like around it balls deep or like how
around it are you talking Joe that you
you know how what's the range you know
these are questions I I'm curious but
also not curious
to well so so this all takes me back to
this messaging and all this because
because what they did in the SNL SK my
my my view of it was they tried to tie
the right-wing Ted Cruz big birds this
big scary monster which is absolutely a
losing message I believe I think they
lost that message as soon as Ted hit
tweet if you try to have an argument
with a fake bird who technically on sixy
Old six-year-old bird six years old he
aged in bird years
but you know the bird has been doing
this since the 70s right big bird has
been doing since 1972 the measles
vaccine on the show no one had an issue
then but all of a sudden it's this Hot
Topic and people don't want it but at
the end of the day if you're trying to
have an argument with an a Twitter
account that repr presents a
six-year-old fictional Bird on a kids TV
show you
lost done don't don't even don't hit
it's not even it's not even a starter on
culture wars really you could you could
start the draft and then abandon it like
there's no need because you're gonna be
made fun of you know what you know what
was one of the best things that came out
of this Ted Cruz Big Bird fight was that
there is an account now it's called Uh
big bird for Senate or something like
that you seen got he's got the whole
team right and yeah he's got Cookie
Monster and Elmo and Burton Ernie I
think's in there it's great accounts
they're doing a great job on Twitter you
know totally [__] roasting Ted Cruz
and and really roasting Texas in the
meantime and that's what I mean by
capturing the messaging so this [__]
idea that somehow big birds is big scary
monster is Democrats because Ted Cruz
and the right wants to have wars like
that Democrats and and the the pro
democracy lowercase D Democrats out
there pro-democracy people need to get
Gra grab that messaging and start
pounding them with it just like what
happened like when they when they were
complaining about Mr Potato Head getting
canceled and doctor they were
complaining about that another and the
whole country like what the [__] you
talking but the other thing too is like
I think Ted Cruz wakes up his daily
routine is just to get annoyed by
something right it's anything it could
be someone walking down the street and
he would get annoyed by it it would be
you know obviously you know someone can
say whatever about his wife Heidi and he
won't get annoyed by it and then there's
the uh uh recently there was a photo of
Biden and he was going to net I think
for Holiday right to go visit family
Thanksgiving whatever it is right uh and
then Ted Cruz immediately was like
complaining about him taking leave and
it's like I never heard
saw read anything about Ted Cruz uh
being annoyed about Trump going golfing
for the Thousand time that he did uh as
opposed well why would he why would he
that's not that's not a culture war that
you can push on to the radical socialist
right but to your point that is the
narrative right they're going to push
they're going to talk about these
trivial things these things that uh
don't really matter in the grand scheme
as in my personal opinion is as a
distraction point so they're going to
use all these things that get you all
hot and bothered and they cause a large
commotion and they they drive this
distraction so that they can do these
other things in the background um so
people don't focus on them much like
they try to you know um like cause a
bunch of traffic in the courts because
they've got bigger cases they want to
deal with that they don't want to shine
light on so they make them busy with
smaller little issues that you know you
have to decide for the Democrats like is
this worth pursuing legally or not or do
we let them go get away with this one
thing right and you're I mean you're
referring to like the Bandon executive
privileg thing is that what you're
saying right right well so so here's
here's what I I think too because you
know you know I I hear this a lot in in
in our side the again the lower lower D
Democrats the pro- Democracy part of
this country they're like oh we need to
not be so focused on the distractions
and and and talk about issues like
that's all fine and good but the problem
is you don't get to have you don't you
do not you do not get to have the
discussion or the negotiation for
minimum wage if these people take power
you don't that's not like you're not
going to be able to focus on minimum
wage you're not going to focus on
universal healthare or or even issues
that are inside the Big Bird bill the
bill back better bill or or the
infrastructure build that they passed or
maybe even more covid relief or supply
chain relief that we may need in this
country in the next year for inflation
and things like that you're not you
can't you're not going to have those
discussions if they win right I mean we
can barely I mean we're we're bar like
uh you know I'd say barely having those
discussions now and trying to decide
what's the more important thing we have
power right yeah and it you know and
also the the whole like we have power
thing you know and the whole like this
is a rigged election I just side note I
just love the idea that we put in this
like Supreme plan by Soros and everyone
else and it was that the Democrats were
going to take over win the presidency
and we're like you know what actually
let's just keep it 50-50 you know right
right right well let's make sure that we
can't get the the so socialist radical
blood sucking cabal agend
let's let's get the election but let's
make we can't get that right exactly and
you're like so it wasn't rigged it
played out right right right and if we
did re and honestly um I I think I
actually think that this is all
projection like the rigged thing and the
like they're they're right now like as
we speak on this podcast they are in
back rooms why they're distracting
distracting us with culture wars with
CRT and JFK J and all this Voodoo cult
stuff this Q andon cult stuff why
they're distracting us with all that
they're in back rooms uh shifting around
election districts to make sure they can
gerrymander up the Congress because I'm
telling you I'm telling you what their
plan is I'm I'm [__] telling you I
know what their plan is their plan is to
take back the house and make Donald
Trump the speaker of the house there is
they're going to say it they're going to
say it they're going to say it out there
on the campaign Trail they're going to
say hey do you want these Trump humping
Q Andi
members of Congress that are going to be
running they're going to be saying hey
do you want us to make Donald Trump the
speaker of the house and Crown himself
King they're going to start to say that
[__] because it's desperation because
the majority of the country doesn't
actually believe this stuff and I've
said this before and and some people you
know kind of yeah that's kind you
shouldn't say that but 81 million people
81 million people did not vote for Joe
Biden I'll agree with the MAA Trump
umbers that 81 million people did not
vote for Joe Biden 81 million people
voted against Donald Trump I think that
is the truth and I think it's no more
the truth than you look at the
California recall what happened with
Larry Elder versus Gavin Nome which
Gavin Newsome is no you know like hero
anyone I mean I mean Gavin new isn't bad
but he's not Larry Elder right yeah yeah
and I ALS you live you live in
California so tell us yeah it's it's uh
it's definitely not as bad as uh as
everyone or the right wants make it
right like let's just be clear about
this like the recall was something that
was started uh out of just a a dislike
hatred for Gavin Nome this wasn't like a
CO thing obviously the the things that
happened during Co with like French
Laundry and whatever didn't help it only
worsened and obviously Co gave them the
extension that they needed to get the
signatures but at the end of the day
like the way that he handled covid you
know uh Surplus in funds uh Aid relief
for
unemployment um the the the just overall
uh planning lockdown and protective
measures that we did in California above
and beyond other places and then you
compare that to Red states where they're
like oh yeah freedom and red States
doing so great and it's like well your
Co numbers are up your unemployment is
down or like unemployment is up uh and
you don't have the ability to care for
the people or you just don't care about
the people to care for the people um and
so in California it's it's it's not like
what it's not this hell Escape right
we're not in the [__] like
Thunderdome out here in well I I mean it
depends it depends on which lens you
look through because the rest of the
world kind of looks through the lens and
says holy [__] California is burning
with wildfires they're out of [__]
water because of global warming I mean
it really is a dire situation you look
yeah I mean but you look at that and say
like oh all these problems are Happ in
California you know environmentally it's
we shouldn't we do something about that
that's right so so which party is going
to do something to make sure it's it's
Pro Pro democracy it's it's Pro the
American people I mean we had the
Republicans this week come out and start
to talk about how physical
infrastructure is bad for the American
people because it's a win for Joe Biden
Mark Meadows said it on TV said it's bad
because it's a win for Joe Biden forget
about a win for the American people it's
a win for Joe Biden so it's radical
socialism that's going to destroy our
country right however at the same time
when Trump was you know saying like he
was you know infrastructure weak right
infrastructure decade people have been
joking about whatever right uh but at
the same time it's like if Trump had
done and passed the exact same bill the
praise and love would be out just
pouring out of their mouths to be like
the great king himself Donald Trump
passed this infrastructure deal that no
one else could have done his great
business Acumen blah blah blah all that
[__] that they like to just circle
jerk around themselves but but at the
end of the day it's for the hatred of
the party and Biden that they're
unwilling
to uh publicly
state that they are in support right
privately like to themselves they know
it's great and they know they need it
especially some of these states that are
dealing with like flooding and and
bridges and Roads that are and breaking
down and you know causing because like
it's all it's chain action right like
you have roads that aren't great then it
cost issue to cars people need to get
repaired to cars they can't get their
job so on and so forth there's like a
domino effect right it it not only has a
physical effect but an economical effect
as well right so all these people these
Republicans who complain about this
radical socialism that comes with this
infrastructure deal you know private to
them privately to themselves uh are I
think I mean I know that they are
actually for it but they can't say it
because it goes against The Narrative of
the party and if they were to public
right it goes against the Q andon cult
stuff and if they were to talk against
it it would be the same moment that was
what Mark Meadows said or was it m I
forget which one stated uh for anyone
who voted against the 13 that voted
against their the party they should be
expelled it was it was in that same
interview yeah right it's just it's just
an insane concept and really I mean you
know talk about in the interview it's
cult mentality right again this is this
is the thing um with the messaging that
I'm talking about is that we have to
steal these M we have to win in these
like even though big bird is [__]
and the CRT Voodoo is [__] the JFK
Jr stuff is [__] um we have to win
in these in these battles we have to win
these culture War battles like in the
Writ writtenhouse case not just get him
convicted we have to win in that
narrative we have to win that it is not
a good idea for Vigilantes to go shoot
people that's not a good idea we have to
win in that in that space and we have to
get people to to be engaged and active
speaking of people being engaged and
active uh today's interview we
interviewed uh the Midas Mel's Brothers
Brett and Jordy with mest touch and the
mightest touch podcast and they talk
about the mightest mighty in this
interview and the Coalition and I
believe that's a huge part of what this
messaging is going to be is that it's
going to take a lot of coalitions not
just the mightest mighty but it's also
going to take pro-democracy people out
there who who are associated with
whatever group or not even associated
with a group at all that are going to
have to get engaged rather it's on
Twitter rather it's doing what we're
doing trying to create content trying to
create a message out there for people to
listen to and maybe grab a hold of or
going registering Democrats to vote
pro-democracy voters or or or go vote
for pro democracy candidates that's
going to be important too so all that
stuff's important but speaking of the
the interview it was a fantastic we
recorded it uh prior to this but it's a
fantastic interview we had a lot of fun
with the game um but and we're going to
play the interview here in just a second
but what was the thing that you took
away from the interview if you could
tell our audience what to hang on to
here to to stay tuned here about this
interview um well I was I was very
fascinated because I don't I don't think
I've ever really heard the like the
origin story from the horse's mouth you
know like like like how M's touch
started right like how it started you
know I heard stories is like go three
brothers you know two of them don't live
too far from where I am here in Los
Angeles uh and it's just interesting to
see like how are you trying to get him
to come to like your house and have
dinner or something is that what you
know that's it's an open invite it's an
open invite for Brett and Ben if they
want to come by you know yeah hang out
yeah we'll Grill it'll be great you know
yeah do do hot girl yeah yeah exactly
right or they want to invite me over you
know right right whatever whatever it is
right right I see what's going on here
but I would say that you know I I
haven't really heard from them
specifically the story and I would say
that uh it it's incredibly impressive
what they were able to do and they talk
about it uh from sitting at home during
the pandemic right and turning this into
a whole a movement right pack a movement
right a network like a platform um for
voices to call out the [__] of the
right right and and do it in a way that
message it correctly so so let's let's
go to a quick break and after the break
we'll get right into the interview stay
stay tuned because right after this
break is the interview with the my
zealous Brothers Brett and Jordy from
midest
Dutch we'll be right back Mark 60
seconds this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing NY P's mail do
you feel exposed to a government that
doesn't share your patriotic values if
any of these describe you then you're in
luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to my
new product paron blanket I've got you
covered paron blanket specifically Works
to make you feel safe and cozy after
your involvement on January 6th and if
you're one of the other members of
Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too paron blanket is made of
a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're 100% made in
the USA don't delay and get your paron
blanket today for just
$99.99 actual pardon not
guaranteed the Tony Michaels podcast
Wednesdays at 400 p.m. Eastern 300 p.m.
central watch live on YouTube on Twitter
and twitch download on Apple and Spotify
now here's
[Applause]
Tony I want to bring in our special
guest today so without further Ado I
want to welcome the melis brothers Jordy
and Brett Jordy and Brett thanks for
joining us here on the Tony Michaels
podcast hi Jordy hi Brett how are you
guys how's it going do great what's
happening guys doing fantastic we're
happy to have you so so um I I want to
start off with a couple questions here
because uh I know there's a huge mest
Mighty Coalition out there that is going
to need to uh be part of what is going
to happen next year in these primaries
because we've seen this morning this uh
of course we are pre-recording this but
this morning we seen a uh an audio tape
come from Jonathan uh Carl he uh he was
interviewing Trump for his book about
the January 6 as I call it Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup and I think I I think it's
very relevant uh especially to not not
just midest touch but also the midest
mighty because I I and I don't know
maybe you guys can tell me what what is
midest touch how did this start and why
is midest mighty so important not just
to touch but our democracy well first
off these tapes make Richard Nixon look
like Mr Rogers right the more we find
out about Donald Trump just the more
horrifying it becomes and I know Jordy
and I always say this on our show on the
mightest touch podcast but it's like how
do kids even learn about Watergate now
like they must be like oh that's all
they did well oh that's it okay and they
got almost got impeached for that like
really he had to resign for that like
when you look at the criminality of what
Trump did it's just mindblowing but let
me get back to your question and let's
not get off the rails too early as I
like to do um what was your question it
was about mest touch the well I I I want
to know how did how did minus touch
start but but not just just how it
started more more about the mest mighty
and the mest mighty Coalition because I
believe they're going to be an important
part of helping us save our democracy
because it's not just the mightest
mighty that you have now and I and I
know I I know you guys have built this
this movement and really the Midas
Mighty has kind of built their their
movement in inside of Midas Touch I
think you guys really believe that um
and and how important is that to our
democracy but
really what is at stake here and what
does it mean and you know just in
general no doubt well the mightest
mighty is the name of our followers or
basically anyone who's kind of pro
democracy I don't even really we don't
even really care like what side of the
political political Spectrum you're on
as long as you are fighting for
democracy and are committed to upholding
those values you know we welcome you and
it's really a movement that created on
that they created on their own and
without the mightest mighty we're just
three brothers tweeting and three
brothers running ads and things so it
really makes it special like the fact
that we were able to create this
movement and that this movement kind of
exists and has this life beyond us which
I think is really special and I think it
fits in the ethos of how Midas Touch
began I mean we started as Three
Brothers we didn't start as activists we
didn't start as political people we
started as three brothers who were uh
quarantined due to covid and were
working from home with all of our
individual jobs Jordy an award-winning
marketer I was an editor at the Ellen
degenerous show and uh and ran their
post- production Department there and
and Ben our older brother who's not here
right now he uh is an attorney who
represents Colin Kaepernick and is
colum's business partner and does a
whole other Bevy of civil rights cases
and things like that but we were sitting
home away from our offices and we're
watching the news we're watching Co hit
our Shores and we're watching a response
which was just a complete disaster and
we always knew Trump was horrible but we
never really had time to breathe and
think oh [__] like we got to do
something about this and now we had a
literal existential threat a disease
coming to our Shores and a maniac
telling people to drink bleach and to
take UV ray light and to and that
everything was going to be okay that
there was going to be 12 cases going
down to zero and the more he said [__]
like that the more I was like we are
[__] like this is It's game over like
this is going to be it and so really M
just touch started out of panic and we
didn't know how we could help but we
knew we had to do something and so at a
certain point the three of us you know
went from uh Angry texting each other to
okay how do we take this out of our
iMessage thread and how do we do
something about it right and so we kind
of connected on a phone call and we were
like hey like if we started a website
might as touch.com and you'll see that's
still built into like our Twitter name
minus touch.com if we started a website
um where we could just get our thoughts
out there you know like we could write
blog posts we could get like cool people
to write news but do it from a an angle
that is you know Pro this country and
pro like saving this country like do you
think like anyone would give a [__] and
we were like I don't know but let's do
it and so like I spent the weekend I
built this website which no longer
exists it was mest touch.com um we
started spending
uh you know five to 10% of our days
doing our actual jobs and the rest of
our Day writing articles for mest
touch.com and we were starting to get
like pretty
good pretty good readership I mean
nothing in comparison to any real you
know news site or whatever but stuff
that made us happy um but you know at
this point we only had like a few
hundred followers really and like we
were just grinding and like trying to
like just get our message out as as best
we could and then the real game changer
was the first video we made which used
Ronald Reagan's are you better off uh
debate performance against Jimmy Carter
in 1980 and ju deposed the things he was
saying with the realities of Trump's
America with empty shelves with
unemployment lines down the block with
covid which just a complete cluster [__]
that we were seeing and that video went
super viral kind of immediately and we
were like oh okay uh that's so you
thought hey we've got something here
we've got something here then this is
what people are our liking and so for
the next few weeks we were still doing
our articles and things but we were
really like we got to do more stuff like
this and so we started churning out
these videos one after the next after
the next and each one started gaining
more and more steem and then I would say
the next really really big one home run
was we did a video called The Snake um
which used the speech that Trump would
the racist uh take on these song lyrics
that Trump would use at his rallies um
to bash uh undocumented immigrants
coming into this country as some sort of
poison we use those words to really show
that the poison was Donald Trump himself
and that he was actually speaking about
himself and so what really happened was
we started out the whole gqp projection
thing exactly the whole gqp projection
and it really all started because you
know we were making these videos we had
no money we had no nothing like we had
no idea what we were doing um and but we
knew like we had access to all this
footage and so our strategy became well
let's just use the footage and use that
to create these ju to positions against
each other rather than having a narrator
that's like in a country where you
know in a world where Donald Trump wants
to be dictator yeah and so that sort of
uh that sort of constraint actually
helped our creativity and helped us do
things that other people weren't quite
doing in the field then one video took
off after the next and then we were like
okay well how do we get a what if we
wanted to get a billboard up to the
effect of this video what if we wanted
to like get a TV ad going like how do we
do that I like how you jump I like how
you jump from like viral video to
Bill like okay we got a vir we got to
start buying Billboards
baby that was also one of the big things
that was that was one of the big things
though too Brett right like veryy from
the onset of mid's touch like we always
had sort of like audacious goals and we
always wanted to find ways to really you
know get into the communities and really
be active and so naturally I I'll let
Brett continue the story but the next
phase of this was taking out of you know
the Twitter and social media videos and
then into real world sort of situations
so Billboards became a big component uh
canvasing efforts became a huge
component mailers became a huge
component uh Brett what am I leaving out
here all the above and more and but when
we started we were like imagine if we
could get one billboard up in a swing
state like how how like if we get one
billboard up in a swing state how
awesome would that be because that
seemed like the most financially
feasible thing we could do at the time
and we literally did not know how the
hell to do any of this and so we started
calling every attorney we knew who put
us wait wait isn't isn't isn't I think
you know an attorney don't you know
here's like an on staff attorney he's
he's on retainer he's on retainer no I
mean he's not here let's bash him Ben
does civil rights cases which and and he
does a lot of stuff that kind of Agents
do in terms of deal making and things
and so that doesn't really cross over
into the campaign Finance realm which is
its whole beast and so we needed to get
touch with campaign because there are so
many rules around this stuff so
ultimately after talking to like a
billion campaign Finance lawyers and
figuring out okay how do you go from you
know cute viral internet video
to to to TV ad to uh billboard you know
like everybody basically said oh well
you need to create what's called an
independent expenditure committee I'm
like what I don't even know what these
words mean I don't even know what this
is and so we ended up uh you know we
ended up forming though midest touch as
a pack um which was something we really
did didn't even know what it was I mean
my only familiarity with it is that
everyone hates packs and that um and
that Steven colar like started a pack to
mock the whole system or whatever but it
became you scummy you scummy
packs that's that's our whole impression
of it so like when we started it we're
like G like that's the only way that
you're really able to like do this but
we were like okay if this is the only
way the campaign Finance system allows
us to actually take these ads raise
money to actually like run these ads in
places put the proper disclaimers on it
so we don't get into trouble and do all
that then okay let's do it like we need
to play Within the rules of our dumb
political system and and we need to
Fight Fire with Fire if this is what the
right's doing then we need to be able to
punch back and with with our ads and we
need to go 10 times harder than they're
going or we're going to be left in the
dust so so in other words so in other
words you you wanted to use democracy to
save democracy as opposed to what the
fascists are doing is try to use
democracy to destroy it yeah no 100 perc
I I think one of like the funniest
ironies are so that there's a pack
called end Citizens United and right
it's kind of it's kind of contradictory
because ending citizens united would
kind of end the whole pack thing and so
but it shows you like you have to be
able to get in the ring if you wanna if
you want to actually be in the fight and
so we did that and you know just really
put our heads down and kept doing these
videos and then kept trying to figure
out okay well what's the next thing we
could do what's the next thing we could
do and and realized that there was
really a gap in Democratic messaging and
people really felt like Democrats
weren't appropriately targeting
Republicans in the proper way and
weren't taking on Trump in the proper
way and we remembered vividly how Trump
really ran social media in 2016 I mean
you know it's easy to mock right drove
the conversation there 2015 I mean it
was all and so then we came in and we
were like all right like you're going to
like you're going to like make up this
like [__] lie about what's going on
well you know Boom Like This is actually
the truth let's hit him with the truth
Non-Stop and not even let that become
the viral moment but let's make our take
become the viral moment and then let's
not only respond but let's set the
conversation and let's try to you know
make sure that people are aware you know
of what's really going on in this
country and the stakes of the election
and so things really just built super
organically and and we gained this huge
following and then you know we had the
mightest mighty many of whom have been
with us since we had like a thousand
followers some of whom you know started
coming you know last week and they're
just like a dedicated group of
incredible people who I think by the way
are also like us accidental activists
meaning they never consider themselves
political their entire life and then
they saw something in mightest touch
maybe the fact that we also never
considered ourselves political our
entire lives but knew the stakes of what
was going on in our country and realiz
TI
[__] so Jordy let me let me ask you
a few questions about the minus Mindy
because I know I know that that's kind
of at the end of your guys's podcast you
always give the shout out to him so
shout out to the mightest mighty so I
have a couple questions do it do it
again shout out to the mightest mighty
there you go so so let let's talk about
the minus Mighty with Jordy for a second
because Jordy um did you see this coming
I mean did you think I mean when you
when when this all started to happen I
know you're the kind of the marketing
brain of everything so I know you know
you were probably putting together like
how do we make this movement how do we
get it out there how do we get in front
of people but did you ever see this
mightest Mighty thing coming look like I
sort of said in the beginning I think we
always had like really audacious goals
from the beginning and what I really
wanted to put at the Forefront of this
is just the authenticity of of the Three
Brothers just like we don't pretend to
be anything we're not and we haven't
since day one and so very early on I
started to see that sort of resonating
with uh the Twitter Community very
specifically of people who just like you
know we were talking to them like people
and not like we were some super highbrow
politicians because we you know were
worried about the same things that they
were so the short answer is no I didn't
see the extent of it but I knew that
there was always going to be a
passionate base of people sort of like
us that we could connect with I had no
idea would get this big but they are
just the absolute greatest I mean I
cannot thank them enough and like I said
like it's all about really genuine and
authentic connections I think that gets
lost in the marketing world because
that's like a buzzword for me for
example from back in my marketing days
is oh we need something to be authentic
like that's always what brands say but
like when McDonald says it for example
it's not going to resonate the same way
than a Grassroots movement and so for me
very early on it was really important to
connect people and have genuine
relationships and communicate them you
know in the Twitter DMS or or like just
replying to tweets and stuff like that
and really just make myself available
and as open and you know as I could be
about what our plans were uh cue them in
because at the end of the day they were
on the mission alongside us and we
wouldn't be who we are today without
that I Gotta Give Jordy too a ton of
credit and sorry to interrupt but Jordy
really um in a special way uh is such an
inal part of building that mightest
Mighty community and back when I was
busy you know busier than ever cranking
out the videos and stuff Jordy made it a
priority to respond to every single
person who messaged us to you know speak
with everybody check in see how they
were doing and really help build this
moment in a you know direct you know
authentic way and I think Jordy just
deserves a ton of credit for for that
and the whole marketing machine behind
Midas well I mean to to Really to make
to make My mest Touch look authentic and
to you know since Ben isn't here to make
Ben look
authentic probably probably was a huge
huge beat in and of itself right Jordy
is that from the marketing perspective
no no no Ben Ben's is genuine as they
come as
well well we got to give him a little he
I know I know I know but he's GNA beat
me up later if I too hard on himself he
can only he can only come after you
through the microphone on the podcast I
think I think what makes it also special
too is that we each really do bring in
our own you know special skill set and
and you know I I I always love giving
Brett his flowers he was so nice and
kind to give me mine just now like
during the election cycle specifically
he was cranking out like three videos a
day and that momentum is also what
carried us because with see this guys
you see this those circles don't just
happen yeah right aged aged aged by
video
clips I I real quick quick tangent I
looked at a video breett that we had
done um like very early on it was the
first one with elix actually uh and we
look so much younger these last like
year and a half have aged all of us
tremendously your aging is like the
Aging of the president they're like
every for every two every year for us
it's two years for them doubt about it
what I was saying is Brett was cranking
out and he still continues to like even
Beyond just the video work the whole
operation of it it's really at the end
of the day the Three Brothers like
making the key decisions on everything
and so there's just Monumental amount of
work that goes into that and you know
without Brett sort of you know steering
the ship and Ben you know steering the
ship uh I don't know where we would be
so I have one more question then I'm G
to let Gabe see if he's got any question
questions for you guys my question is um
and to either one of you so we were
talking about Billboards earlier what
what was your favorite billboard tell me
about your favorite like the most the
most exciting billboard that you had
grinches of Christmas grinches gr
Georgia grinches of Georgia is that what
it was absolutely so uh during the
Georgia Senate uh race you had leer uh
looting leer and chicken Purdue as we
framed it and this campaign was really
freaking amazing because this was like a
movie Campaign and let me just take a
step back so obviously during that time
like that all eyes were on Georgia right
we needed we needed alaf and Warick to
win those seats that was a necessity and
so we had to figure out ways to message
that look looting Kelly leer and chicken
Purdue are not right for the people of
Georgia so how did we sort of do this
well it was coming up sort of around
Christmas time when the big debates were
happening and we did our Billboards that
framed lud and Kelly leer chicken Purdue
as the grinches of Georgia literal
grinches uh also during that time Brett
uh and our team made an incredible
grinches of Georgia video that really
explained uh this in just like a very
dral way and the video is probably one
of my favorites that we've ever done and
we had a uh billboard truck driving
around all parts of Georgia I'm talking
Roy Parts City Parts everywhere in
Georgia we were hitting uh with this
billboard truck to make sure it was
getting maximum visibility where we were
playing the full length commercial on
top of that we had our Billboards the
grinches of Georgia up around there and
then we also sent mailers and had
canvassers so people in Georgia were
just getting just uh entrenched with
this messaging about how you know luding
Kelly ler who's not even from Georgia is
not right for them and same with Purdue
who hides out in basically an island you
know off of Georgia which is truly truly
bizarre that they're just not right for
that the cool thing about that campaign
was that you viewed it more like a movie
premiere than like a political ad and so
we hit we hit everybody from like Jordy
said from every single angle um with
that like you know it was the mailers
the the door knocking the billboard the
the TV commercial the whatever and we
have to be creative with that when
you're a small organization going
against groups that have billions and
billions and billions of dollars in
funding to get that extra attention you
know um I'm gonna have a different
answer than Jordy on my favorite Bill
award so my favorite billboard just kind
of on its own um were the two we did in
Vegas um early on over the summer
because we did one that was Trump
cancelled and it it but by the way let
me set the stage this is like the one of
the biggest Billboards in the entire
country it's the biggest billboard on
the Vegas Strip I can't even like
describe to you how large this thing is
and it was just right in the heart of
the strip and so the first one we did
was Trump canceled and so it said Trump
canceled on one side and then it went
Trump canceled your wedding Trump
canceled your grandparents Trump
cancelled your birthday party you know
it went through all those various things
and then at the end it said go to
maga2020.com for more which was a domain
that we had bought because Trump forgot
to buy it right um and then that was and
then that website was a website that
just spoke about how horrible Trump is
and how creepy he is and just how
terrible of a human being he is and then
we followed that up pretty easy pretty
easy
stuff there's always a tweet there's
always a video always some sound and
then a few weeks later we followed up on
the same screen we had three panels of
trump golfing um doing his horrific golf
swing and it said if we renamed covid-19
golf would Trump begin to care and that
one was [__] incredible like just so
so so incredible and that's when you
know we'd be getting the news every day
about Co getting worse then we'd hear
Trump spending his 3,000th day at the
golf course today and you're like what
is going on so those are my those are my
two favorite they were flashy they were
big they were in the Vegas Strip which
was an interesting place at the time
especially because like no one was
actually it was like it was like dead
right but it served as like
a that almost made it eerier and it
ended up you know our strategy was let's
buy the biggest [__] billboard like
in the country um the most flashy one
that really shows what the problems are
there and then when that gets seen that
itself will be news like right it'll be
news
interational news and so like the first
the Trump canel one as somewhere near
like 3 million views on on Twitter alone
and was picked up by you know the I I
think it has double that I think it's I
think it's closer to six at this point I
mean that thing really took off yeah and
that was really one of our other
strategies too not to cut you off here
is making sure that these Billboards
have life not just in this one
intersection of of life but you know
that they could then live in digital
spaces as well and keep the conversation
going I think too many times people just
want to have a conversation in a silo
but when you actually allow more people
to speak on an issue uh it brings to
light more of the issues and problems
that I think the entire world is facing
right that's the antithesis of the
Republican party right so let's throw
the G gab do you got any questions for
theer yeah yeah so the the mightest
mighty right you talked about
authenticity having that Grassroots like
movement you know like at what point did
you realize after the Inception or
creation of midest touch we like all
right we've we now like when was the
label like dawned on them and given to
them to be like we have a group that can
now like that is supporting us you know
I don't know the very first time I think
it was on stuttering John's podcast and
why it came up there was because we've
noticed that uh some folks started to
and this was June of 2020 or no April
April or May of 2020 we started to
notice that people started to change
their Twitter handles once they you know
start to really understand us personally
to Midas XYZ for example so for example
we have you know Midas Kesha who's been
pretty much a day one a day one uh Midas
Stacy's been a day one um Midas Wendy
shout out shout out all these truly
wonderful wonderful people Midas just
everyone is so amazing and so we started
to notice that these folks started to
change their handles and I I I think it
really just came up sort of or organic
based off of that because Stuttering
John had noticed that um that a lot of
folks were changing their names and he's
like are these you know are they
associated with you directly like do
they work with mest touch we're like no
they're just the mest mighty they're the
best they're the best group of loyal
followers that are out there um and I
think that really that's just how the
name sort of came to be and and it stuck
and it resonated because you know who
doesn't want to be part of the mightest
SMY y all the best I remember Jordy in
the beginning too like if I would say it
wrong Jord very upet like say say say
can they would flip it they would go
they would go Mighty Mighty Midas and it
who day who's day wait a second of
course we'd be like so we'd be like so
we got the the the the mighty Midas huh
and J be like they're the mest mighty
you sons of [__] Reaching Across the
microphone I said midus Mighty I I have
some very angry angry texts that I've
saved when I had to correct them I also
get very offended when they don't put
the in front of the midest touch podcast
really stresses me out oh so like it's
like a marketing thing or is this just
like OCD I I'm just a weirdo on that
note the geordies are weirdo let's take
a quick break and we'll be right back
with a game of Brotherly Love don't go
anywhere stay right there we'll be right
back find us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod and at the Tony Michaels or be lame
and don't [__] Bon heads we'll be
back in 60
[Music]
seconds I am so excited about a new
movie you guys have probably heard about
this movie the supporters it's starring
the good liars this movie is [__]
hilarious and I think it might have been
a mistake but for some reason I got an
advanced screening of this movie it's
about two doofuses that get wrapped up
in the MCA Trump bumping go [__]
boneheads the characters names are Derek
and Dale and they have a podcast called
the Derek and Dale show that they do out
of the back of a minivan that they live
out of they're pissing in jugs they're
chasing their dreams of having this hit
cable show on Fox News and when that all
gets crushed they decide to do their own
research and travel all across the
country during the 2020 presidential
campaign armed with only their white
male fragility and a camera they run
into the likes of Andrew Yang Tom Styer
Elizabeth Warren President Joe Biden Mar
hoofoot green Don booger sugar Jr they
even have a close encounter in the film
with the Cheeto dust mobster Grandpa
poopy pants himself Donald Trump is in
the film you cannot miss this one it is
a fantastically funny movie starring the
good liars you know these comedians from
their viral videos out Occupy Wall
Street and MAA rallies and even the
January 6 Insurrection that footage from
the January 6 Insurrection is in the
film do not miss this movie it is
released on November 4th go to the
supporters mov.com can reserve so you
see the movie first you have to see this
[__] movie The Good Liars present in
association with mest pictures executive
producers Michael Rapaport the
supporters don't [__] miss
it catch Tony's twitch stream the [__]
list Roundup at
twitch.tv/ thee Tony Michaels we're back
to the king of Brilliance this is the
Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast welcome back to the Tony
Michaels podcast we have the melis
brothers here of minus touch Jordy and
Brett and what we thought we would do we
do something fun we would play a game of
Brotherly Love Now I know I know both of
you are really big sports fans right
Brett absolutely I feel like I feel like
this feel like whatever we're about to
do is about to be completely rigged no
no no not rigged at all not we're going
to stop the steal and we're going to
make we're doing a sports we're doing a
sports competition between no not well I
mean I mean uh it has nothing to do with
like uh treadmills or or or you know
actually using sports equipment here
it's it's it's a trivia game we're going
to shot it did a trivia
[Music]
game okay so we we've got the two
brothers here let's go over the rules
the rules I'm going to ask five
questions each question is worth one
point the first one to ring in on their
buzzer will get a chance to answer that
question get it wrong and your opponent
will have a shot for the point Whoever
has the most points after five questions
wins are you ready let's rock all right
let's play Let's play brotherhood's
trivia sports edition Gabe please keep
scoring and watch those Buzz for me all
right question number one how many
players are on a baseball
team 20 we're 26 Jordy Jordy with the
answer 26 is that your answer Jordy
that's my answer uh that the answer is
not that's not correct Brett Brett Brett
your your uh your the question is how
many players are on a baseball team how
many players are on a baseball team just
G throw out an answer yep is you already
low or
high I I don't
know uh 40 40 no that that is
incorrect the answer the answer to the
question number one is nine players nine
players who whoa whoa
whoa you said not on the field of course
I knew it's
nine I'm sorry I'm sorry no points are
awarded no point no points are awarded
no points are awarded for question
number one I will take that
point yeah Gabe Gabe gets Point number
one even though he's not playing okay
question outrageously question number
two question number two we're going to
stop the steal here question number two
what what was Wilt Chamberlain's record
for the most points in a single game
Jordy again Jordy what's your answer
what was Wilt Chamberlain's record for
the most points in a single in my hand
I'm seeing the picture in my mind he's
holding up you know the white piece of
paper that says it I think it says 101
on
it God that's wrong that's wrong we're
gonna give the question to BR let me
repeat the question Brett so we make
sure that you have a good chance and you
can't accuse me of rigging the questions
question number two is to you for one
point what was Wil Chamberlain's record
for the most points in a single game I
mean this is like a super famous thing
right like it's known asber he's holding
the piece of paper and it says you know
it's known as it's known as the 100
point game right it's 100 right he's
Googling it right
now it is 100 points 100 points is the
answer okay I'm gonna have to double
check that you don't have to double
check it I have the answ
right do you think I came without the
answers these are these sound possibly
like alternative facts they they well
they could be alternative questions
alternative answers and alternative
effects question alternative question
number three what NFL team what NFL team
was originally called the New York
Titans Jordy again Jordy your answer the
New York Titans
became the Indianapolis cult I I would I
would love to give you a point here but
uh you are way off um we are going to
throw the question to Brett Brett do you
have an answer for what NFL team was
originally called the New York Titans
the New York Titans I'm I'm disappointed
Jordan didn't know this one to be honest
it's clearly like it's it's definitely
the Jets like so here's the thing I just
want to take a step back these questions
are phrased in such a way that are very
confusing oh oh so so the guy
Indianapolis the Indianapolis C right it
so so wait a second wait a second
because I want to say the one guy who
knows more about sports than probably
anyone on this podcast right now is
complaining about the the the questions
being rigged I I tried Le say Tennessee
or something that makes sense stop the
count stop the count okay stop the count
the winner G Gabe are you are you
keeping score here are we are we at
where we at the score what's theore so
far I have one point and Brett has two
just kid Brett has three points this is
humiliating for here's the thing I'm
kind of letting BR win is actually
what's that's brotherly love right there
when I but when I said 26 to to how many
players are on a baseball field were you
just like is is Jordy drunk yeah well I
mean that the audience will let us know
in the comments I I am CU I do want to
know the real answer to that question
because it was not Tony's
answer hey hey I am the one I am the one
asking the questions here and coming up
with the answers this is this is
legitimate trivia questions that I
totally did not steal off the internet
okay number four question stolen
question number four uh this openly gay
player was the first ever to be drafted
by an NFL team what was his name Michael
Sam Michael Sam point point to Jordy he
fin he F he finally answered a question
I didn't even buzz in on that one I'm
just I'm taking the wins where I could
get them now now now I'm by the way I
just looked up how many players are in
an MLB baseball team and it's MLB 26 a
reserve 27 so technically I got two
points oo just going to say that okay
okay well we'll let the scorekeeper
decide I'm just the host here we will
let the scorekeeper decide now I do have
a bonus question about the Michael Sam
answer okay here's the bonus question
for a bonus point from what college was
Michael Sam drafted
Missouri he is he ringing in is he
ringing the
buz I'm not
even buzzed in not only okay BR Brett
Brett Brett buzzed in Brett was first to
buzz in Brett what's what is the answer
to the bonus question I'll go
Missouri that is correct that is correct
let's go in 2014 draft the St Louis Rams
drafted Michael Sam from the University
of Missouri m i z
zouu all right uh so Gabe do we have the
score don't say the score yet one extra
bonus Point here to also say that
Michael Sam wasn't just drafted out of
Missouri he was also SEC Defensive
Player of the Year that year should have
went much higher in the draft that is
that is correct that is correct correct
but not wasn't the question that was
asked so no points are awarded for that
answer than for the fun fact okay number
five question number five this is the
final question this is the final
question for the win I don't know what
you win but this is the final question
the final question is between the
Williams sisters who has won more Grand
Slam title titles Venus or Serena
winner this has to say this has to be a
setup you want me to say Serena so I'm
going to go I'm G to go Venus for Grand
Slams uh here's the problem with this
question that I just realized is that
now that you're wrong Brett to uh Brett
gets to um take the question for the
point Brett do you have an here's let me
let me repeat the question Brett just in
case because jordy's answer was Serena
the question is between the Williams
sisters
whoam no oh that's right no no it was
Venus you are correct
uh who has more Grand Slam titles Venus
or Serena Brett do you have an answer to
this question uh yeah uh uh Serena final
answer you are correct all right all
right thanks for playing d g Gabe let me
let me ask you let's tally up the points
and see Gabe who is our winner here
uh well question one is a a question
that is causing some contention here
uh you know we'll just we'll we'll get
rid of it because I would agree it is a
poorly worded question you know it's
it's you didn't say on the field what
the fuckry when you lose your co-host
yeah see as Jordy stated a baseball team
carries 26 active players with a 27th
allowed for Reserve I mean I I totally
get I'll even give Jordy the point
wow well if I if I still have more
points when you only only if you win do
you get more points are we uh are we
counting that question for the buzzer
situation um you know he did he did ring
in before the buzzer but let's let's go
ahead and give him that one that one
question I mean okay all right so
question one was Jordy question two and
three were Brett question four was Jordy
uh the
bonus uh was yeah there wasn't a buzzer
rang and I I believe I believe we have
to give uh I believe said it but yeah
but did it was it was a tag on I mean
technically it's a bonus so if we look
at it we got one for Jordy on one two
three were Brett four was Jordy the
bonus was Jordy and five was bonus we
have ourselves a tie oh a tie ding ding
ding ding there's a good how about this
can I ask a question for Brett and if
Brett gets it right he wins and Brett
without looking it up who won last year
super
nope can't ask nope is not an NFL
football team we can't ask these
questions because it's unfair because it
already it already happened like you
don't understand exactly yeah the good
news is the good news is I congratulate
both of you on a tie because there there
is there is no prize there there is
literally no prize so uh thank you both
for
[Music]
playing all right guys thanks for
joining us today I really I really
appreciate you guys coming on the
podcast and telling us about the mest
mighty telling us about Mighty touch
mest touch might see see I already
messed Mighty touch Mighty touch Mighty
touch gonna come to your house and he's
gonna teach you about the title mest
Mighty and mest touch thank you for
joining us I really do appreciate you
guys being on the podcast coming here
playing playing sports trivia and uh
giving us the lowdown on your favorite
billboard Gabe do you have anything
before we leave no I just want to say
yeah just again thank you so much for uh
taking time on our day to hang out with
us and uh play the little sports ball
trivia awesome even though even though
they were even though I will admit I did
rig the questions but I was I honestly
was trying to rig it in favor of Jordy
and that's just not how it played out um
Jordy I'm really sorely disappointed I
made sure that Brett and I walked away
with the tie so he wouldn't be that's
good that's good just have to come back
for round two at a later point you know
it'll be an on say I start I start to
have the advantage when the questions
asked are about things prior to
1999 once we get once we get past that
then Jordy takes a leap ahead of me but
you get those older questions when Jordy
still didn't quite know what was going
on in the world young that's where
that's my time to shine you guys well I
mean that's why I threw in the wilt
Chamberlin I threw in the Wilt
Chamberlain I tried to get the chamber I
think I got nervous was was after the is
but hey before we go I also do really
want to say appreciate all the work that
you guys do I mean Gabe your videos are
incredible and all that work is so
special and just thank you for what
you've contributed to the movement it's
awesome an Tony obviously man [__] him
baby let's go [__] them [__] them [__]
shout out to the mest mighty I want to
thank Brett and Jordy for joining us
today I believe we're going to have
there's all kinds of extended interviews
here we talked about all kinds of great
things so I think we should put an
extended interview up on YouTube check
that out I'm sure we'll have a link
somewhere follow it on Twitter I'm sure
we'll get a few people to retweet that
thing cuz there's going to be some
footage that you want to see from this
broadcast so thank you Brett and Jordy
again the my zealous brothers from mest
touch go visit mest touch.com for all
the links thank you for joining us again
guys what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels podcast
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a Maga Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacist the first lesson began
with learning simple phrases and soon I
was putting those words and phrases into
a conversation each lesson takes about
10 to 15 minutes to complete and they're
all really different which keeps things
interesting the app is really smart it
actually keeps track of the words that
I'm struggling with I chose Babel magga
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new magga skills with my in-laws all
lives
matter [__] them [__] [__] them [__]
[__] them [__] them we're back to the
Tony Michaels
[Music]
[Applause]
podcast well how about that sports ball
Brotherly Love
trivia fantastic fantastic fantastic I
really do appreciate uh Brett and Jordy
both joining us taking time out of their
afternoon to join us on the Tony
Michaels podcast and uh we will we will
hopefully have them back again uh I I
know I know you like the the interview
in the game right Mr keeper you were the
official you know I like I said I did
have a point on the board so well that's
true that's true you know like like you
had some uh Brett because because it was
confusing about the uh the actual who
won of course there was no like the
prize was that they got to be on the
show I mean what a prize PR was was just
the you know enjoying the moment of
being with us right and us and us with
them right exactly exactly so it's a
Fant I actually the billboard part after
rewatching the the interview now the
billboard part was one of the most
interesting things I wish we would had
more time like to talk through like each
one of their Billboards because the fact
that they went from like just posting
some video to like buying the biggest
billboard in the entire country and
having the the Grinch the the Grinch
that stole Georgia what whatever the
Georgia the grinches of Georgia that's
it the grinches of Georgia to have just
those two stories was really cool I'd
like to hear like more of the billboard
stories and more like their favorite
content that they created uh for the for
the 2020 election and defeating the
Cheeto dust mobster is the is the main
thing and I think I think minus touch is
like going to be super important and
again not just minus touch but the minus
Mighty more than you know mest touch
themselves and they and they actually
talked about this I think just the the
other day last week on their podcast
like like minus touch wouldn't be
anything without these followers and I
want to put an exclamation point on this
that it's it's not just like mest touch
alone like this is pro-democracy people
everywhere anyone anyone out there who
is pro democracy who who wants to make
sure that our democracy continues in a
form that we recognize right because I
think that's really what they want to do
is is tear down what our democracy
is normally and that's really what
Donald Trump gave them the ability to do
is step outside these boxes of normal
where we don't have like rules and laws
that create um this system that we have
where it's always been like just Norms
especially after the second world war
like Norms towards things like Fascism
and and after the Civil Rights like
Norms towards anti-segregation things
and you know as we tick forward and get
better and better at Society now all of
a sudden they're like know all those
things that we did and all that work we
want that stuff back because that's what
Mo Brooks like I was talking earlier
that's what m books is talking about
when he's saying the infrastructure bill
is socialism in that they're going to
get those Urban people to move to your
your suburban nice yard neighborhoods
right I mean it's crazy I mean that's
the same stuff yeah the same stuff that
Trump was saying before he's like it's
going to ruin your suburbs you're G to
have more Corey Bookers right and it's
like okay right that's that's
it let's you know if we know you're
racist if you're going to say it say it
so you know uh but it's yeah it's just
one of those things where it's
like they're getting they're they're
like going up against the line so
closely as to being those things without
o like overtly being those things and
trying to get away with what they can
and I mean each at each point they're
just testing the limits right January 6
like everything that they pass and every
Bill and everything that they say and
you know everything that goes with it
they're always testing the boundary to
say well now there's precedent I could
do something a little bit more crazy
right or something or or you know or
something like a little bit more
regressive in that way well I I mean I
mean you know we were talking about this
before we came on the air about like you
can even see it in this this undertone
in this writtenhouse trial with this
judge like how much how much can I say
to be overtly for the defendant right
like little bitty things and we were
talking about this case um who tweeted
it out we we were talking about um this
the the the motion to dismiss this on
aist yeah there were a couple Julius Kim
did it and also Don Lewis uh on on
Twitter tweeted about it basically
identifying that the motion by the
defense for a mistrial had been
presented but the judge but judge
Schroeder had not acted on it so so so
what you mean is so what they're talking
about is like they they filed this court
motion to to totally negate the trial
and the judge didn't actually rule in
court on that motion right so it's still
hovering out there so basically There
lives a world where if the jury comes
back and says guilty right the judge can
then say this motion has been accepted
by me which wait a second so so let's be
clear for the audience because what
you're saying and this is why how I
understood it and I even sent you a
message I'm like is this [__] real
because if this [__] is real this is
this is actually pretty scary this is
where I think political violence really
happens when you have this this steing
pot of boiling hot lava that is going to
be poured on this subject where a
verdict comes and it's a guilty verdict
right and a certain group of people are
completely [__] pissed and a certain
group of people like yeah and then you
have the judge which in this scenario in
this hypothetical scenario which can
still exist it still can happen this way
where the judge says oh by the way
remember that motion you were talking
about the other day we're going to do
that and it absolutely even though he's
found guilty the jury is the is the one
who decides whether he's guilty or
innocent the judge can crush it all in
that one moment
turns which then turns the national
narrative now this side's excited this
side's not and that's where this this
Clash of violence could happen right and
so it's that moment of like it literally
is a get out of jail free card right
like the judge at you know like you said
earlier he's been playing footsie I mean
everything from the you know reading the
cookie catalog magazine uh uh you know
even if it was during a 10-minute break
it's still it reflects poorly on the on
the the seriousness or or lack of
seriousness by the judge for the trial
and then you've got the Asian uh racist
joke that was made about the delay
you're talking about the containers and
the food right right and he's making it
he's making a joke about the ports being
clogged up so the Chinese food not
getting there or the Asian food not
getting there uh and then you know today
he's T he and so there's the other thing
that was ridiculous that a lot of people
didn't understand was in cases you'll
have the um you'll have another officer
of the Court pick out the jury members
right so this is where he's picking
names out of the box exactly and so
yesterday what got coverage and I think
rightfully so because it would have been
you know not it wouldn't be it would be
totally normal if anyone who is a a
representative of the Court had done it
but he allowed the defendant Kyle
Rittenhouse to pick out his own jury
members now again it was random so
whatever but the Optics of that isn't
great right so then today judge schroer
goes into oh everyone's talking about
the Optics blah blah blah you know he's
he's complaining about how maybe in the
future possibly in the future he won't
let uh you know TV into his courtroom
and it's like I'm sorry if you don't
like the way that people are criticizing
you for the things that you're doing or
not
doing and and there's a lack of
transparency or or accountability for
your behavior but at the same time uh he
went into the story about how he came to
do this thing he said he was doing a
case and Ray scene 20 years prior and
the reason that he was he did this thing
with he allowed the defendant to pick
out his own jury members he's like now
other courts probably don't do it this
might be the only court that does it but
the reason I did it was at the time uh
when I was trying this case they let one
of the officers of the Court he was like
uh he didn't say he said a
black yeah the black right right oh you
know like it was like oh okay you know
he's clear he's clearly he's clearly
making this over message and I don't
know if the judge is just a [__]
idiot or he's actually playing to this
messaging but I think we'll see uh as
this verdict rolls out let's go to a
quick break and then we'll come right
back we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast
troubleshooting and support are the keys
to good business that's why at AT&T we
are dedicated to offering Superior
Service to all of our customers whoever
you are we are here to help my internet
is not working okay we're going to walk
through some steps right now first I
want you to restart your router and see
if that changes anything starting today
we are proud to announce that AT&T will
be offering our new troubleshooting
feature for customers with a different
point of view we call it Echo every
conservative has opinions mying internet
is down again did someone in your
neighborhood get the vaccine because
that can destroy your router you know
what my neighbor's whole family just got
the fouchy ouchi at AT&T we know every
customer is unique and requires
different approaches none of my Direct
TV channels are working how am I
supposed to watch jogan commentate the
UFC fight I've been told by higher ups
there's a deep State hack and that is
what's causing your outage Soros no
matter the issue or how conspiratorial
it is we'll tell you exactly what you
want to hear and we believe in it so
much that we've decided to fund 90% of
this new feature Echo by
AT&T the Tony Michaels podcast
Wednesdays at 400 p.m. Eastern 300 p.m.
central watch live on YouTube on Twitter
and twitch download on Apple and Spotify
now here's
Tony
thank you thank you for joining us today
we hope you enjoyed the first 2hour
format even though we stumbled and
bumbled around a bit especially there at
the end I don't know if you caught that
but you know it it it happens it happens
it happens in this world of of live
broadcast uh thanks thanks again to Gabe
I'm I'm glad that we have you here on
the show um now now to help us create
content and to get our message out there
and help us with editing and stuff like
that um may maybe eventually I'll hand
over the the directing part because I'm
I'm clearly not that is there is too
much responsibility too much
responsibility oh oh oh I see how it is
so you I I have to take the fall for the
directing is what you're saying well the
podcast does have your name in it that
is true well I mean I am responsible for
the entire thing I guess so yeah so go
follow Gabe uh let's let's uh give gab's
handle here real quick go follow Gabe IM
gab Sanchez on the the Twitter's the Tik
toks and the you're on the Instagrams
too at that right yeah I'm on Instagram
Twitter Tik Tok go follow Gabe stay stay
with Gabe because he's the executive
producer now so I'm sure a lot of
content that you see on his will end up
on here somehow as you see we we had
these great commercials today I don't
know where these commercials came from
but uh we had these great commercials
they look they look legitimate to me
totally totally legit I think they're
real you
obviously can vouch for them probably
I mean the people in the people in them
look great right right absolutely I mean
handsome people right handsome people
well hey your words not
mine all right thanks for joining us
again next week YouTube Twitter twitch
live uh 3 o'clock Central four o'clock
Eastern it's going to be a two another
two-hour episode we already have a guest
lineup uh we'll announce that on Twitter
because I don't think that's 100%
confirmed but we have a couple guests
over the next few weeks because we're
going to have a guest every episode
every episode we're going to go to a
guest every episode so stay tuned to the
Tony Michaels podcast Wednesdays 3:00
Central 4:00 Eastern every single
Wednesday and until next week [__] them
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking